hello everyone so today i want to talk a
little bit about memorization but more
so about becoming familiar with
something and the different layers of
understanding that goes behind it
something that i've always struggled
with especially when learning a new
piece and i just want to relate it to a
little anecdote i have in mind
so when i first moved to new york city
for college i had a special friend who
showed me around and among one of the
first places we went of course was
central park
i remember i was pretty amazed at how
big the whole park was and i was even
more amazed at how my friend really knew
his way around
almost as if he was walking around his
own backyard
of course we hid all the main
attractions within the park
but we went to all these side trails
where i was pretty convinced we'd get
lost very quickly but he always seemed
to know his way around
he had a really good understanding of
the aerial point of view of the park as
if he was following a map in his head
as well as all of the details he knew
from walking around
he'd used key buildings you can see from
the park as a reference and he also knew
how hilly certain aries got the location
of the entrances
the different ponds certain trees and
corners bridges
benches pretty much anything about a
specific section of the park that he
absolutely adored
it was pretty cool how he knew so much
information about the park and he had a
personal connection to so many of the
different parts and characteristics of
all these different areas
so relating this to music a lot of times
i actually don't memorize something
consciously and instead i rely on just
becoming familiar with the music through
repetition
as a result my memory ends up being
inconsistent and also i don't end up
having a full understanding of the music
to relate it back to the park it's as if
i walk through without much thought and
i only have a few points of reference as
i'm navigating through
i think a better approach is to know a
piece in the way that my friend knew the
park which involves different points of
view
sectionalizing having multiple points of
reference
and a thorough understanding of the
layout basically knowing and
understanding something in multiple ways
so for example let's listen to a little
bit of scrub and sonata number four
[Music]
going back to the beginning you can look
at it from a harmonic point of view
[Music]
you can also break it down into multiple
lines different phrases
[Music]
intervallic relations
more descriptive terms
formal analysis
[Music]
and whole list of other ways to look at
a piece
so i hope that made sense i think the
main point is that the more ways we know
something the better off we are and
the more we learn the more that's going
to be possible
so thanks for watching and i'll see you
next time
[Music]